el presidente bielorruso alexandr
lukashenko se ha agarrado con fuerza al
salvavidas en forma de crédito por valor
de 1500 millones de dólares que le ha
ofrecido el presidente ruso vladimir
putin lo suficiente para tener en
funcionamiento del país unos meses más a
pesar de que en las calles hay mucha
gente alzada en su contra vladimir putin
también ha respaldado el proyecto de
lukashenko de reformar la constitución
bielorrusa una idea muy criticada por la
oposición en su país porque ven en ello
una maniobra del líder bielorruso para
no llevar a cabo una transición en el
poder que es lo que le está pidiendo
mucha gente estos días en las calles
lukashenko ha llegado a sochi con la
espera de recibir más apoyo de moscú
pero los rusos también quieren
contrapartidas aunque de momento ha
quedado sobre la mesa el viejo proyecto
ruso de colocar sus bases en suelo
bielorruso una idea que lukashenko
siempre se las ha apañado para anular en
el último momento pero que ahora con una
posición más débil ante moscú va a tener
mucho más difícil rechazar a medio plazo